hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to darkwood now i last
played darkwood in
2014.
and that game was at first in alpha or
early access i can't remember if it was
just
demo but the game was good the game was
scary
and it was different it was unique and i
think it had randomly generated
yadda yaddas but either way the game
came out recently
in full or recently i actually don't
know how many
moons ago oh god lexi and can i just
speak normally i have no idea
either way the game came out sometime in
the past that is indeterminate and i
don't know how much it was
but the reviews are unanimous very good
reviews
so i'm revisiting the game because i
always said that i was going to come
back to it
oh let's go without the immersion
breaking now i have
played this before but i don't know if
there was a prologue before
all right so here we go enough of an
intro intros are dumb anyway let's just
do this
you will not be led by the hand respect
the woods be patient
and focus those are things that i think
everyone can agree i am perfectly
capable of doing and anyone that
disagrees should fight me in the
comments
i think i'd win i think i could take you
raise your hands in the comments down
below if this
is bringing back some memories if you
were here in 2014
or if you've seen it in the recent years
since 2014
i see hatred and fear in their eyes
[Music]
as if i was responsible for the
spreading disease
were you
goodness as if i were the source of all
the misery plaguing this land
are you
[Music]
i have nowhere to hide from them nowhere
to run
the woods have closed us off from the
outside world
oh damn this is cool
we are all doomed we're all doomed
cool all right
that's dope man that is dope oh hey
oh yeah yeah in case you don't remember
it was a top down game i don't have any
skills to use yet well
i wasn't actually asking you to do any
skills what am i doing
oh i opened my inventory uh search
and drag chair what's the use button ah
there we go
right bumper okay good i did that
tables pills sure
my own notepad it's empty
i have no notes much like my mind
completely vacant
i know these notes by heart i don't want
to read them now
a homemade device for producing
moonshine the only edible thing growing
on this land
i still have some left okay dismantling
this now would be suicide
all right dudley noted
squeaky oh this looks familiar
the generator is almost out of juice i
need to find a full gasoline can
i saw a broken tractor to the east maybe
i could find some gasoline there
my old zenith camera that's a zenith all
right
my old useless medical bag and a photo
i don't like that photo that photo makes
my soul itch
i don't know how many faces i'm seeing
in this photo but there's a few too many
i do not like that there's one face
there's a face in the middle a real
funny one there's a face over here
a face down there oh is that a face over
there you know if that's a rorschach
test i think i failed oh my tools
they haven't been sterilized for years
the local patients can't be helped
anyway
oh how funkalunka
all right cool
tell me why that isn't going to kill me
i would like to know exactly how that's
not going to rip my
guts out through my anus great good
oh it's a radio the radio has been
silent for years
well it's awake now although sometimes i
think i can hear voices through the
static
i know these notes by heart i don't want
to read them now
alcohol all right cool do i need all
this crap
probably not i'm taking it anyway
old medical book uh this looks important
this looks real
important um good stuff here
all right rag i don't know why i would
need that stuff but i'm
just gonna stick with it i best not
enter this room right now
why not what's in the room
hey oh oh that can't be good
the lock is jammed a long time ago never
mind
i used to keep useless junk in there
anyway the useless junk but i'm picking
up useless junk that sounds all good to
me i would rather not
open it i spent too much time to
to lock him in there oh cages
this time they're empty oh that's not
good
oh that's not good then hey
oh my dog
i don't think he's going to make it i
shouldn't end his suffering why was he
left
outside oh no i don't have anything to
end it suffering with
it's horrible a large humanoid doll with
a carved out face that's
that's great so i did play through the
prologue before because i'm starting to
give like
very fragmented memo
no oh no everyone avert your eyes
these trees are growing too fast soon i
won't be able to cut them down fast
enough
snare traps i must be careful the woods
are full of them
dead cow yeah get some bones you prick
location path found good great
let me just go into the dark wood
the woods have devoured all the roads
that connected us to the outside world
no one is able to pass through this
thicket
i mean i seem to be able to pass through
the thicket
i seem to be able to pass through just
fine
we're in campfire all right i don't know
what these rags are for
i got an idea what the boards are for
[Music]
these parts of the woods are dark i
should craft a torch
all right crafting eh
torch craft it good
pick up boom porch
there we go
abandoned house i don't know what is
that a hand
that a big hand that a big hand
hand hand hand
like oh hi in a few days it will be
completely absorbed
into what absorbed into what
what is it going to be absorb oh this is
well that's fun
that's fun this is fun
oh yeah repair i don't need to repair it
i'm not gonna stay here that's for sure
i think there's a reason this whole
place
blew what's with the circles surrounding
all these things
i don't remember this part of the
prologue i don't remember any of this
oh tree oh hey bud
hey how you doing i think this one is
still breathing
big metal key there's an exit out of
these woods this key will surely open it
21. how do you know that what do you
mean it'll open it
he's unconscious i've never seen him
around here before
he's only carrying a key and some
journal
since he managed to sneak in here he
must know how to get out
of course he won't help me voluntarily
okay of course yeah of course but that
is of no importance
fascinating excellent
i'm one of those good healthy help
people doctors
i need to get out of this accursed
forest
you hear me rat rat show me how
and i will let you go
okay you happy i sometimes hear her
voice
who she's calling me who
calling me to return home who's home
[Music]
great where is the exit
where
[Applause]
show me where okay oh well how's he
gonna show you if you punch his eyeballs
[Music]
out
oh that's not good i'll kill you like a
dog if i have to yeah you'd know all
about that wouldn't you
this dilweed this dill hole
this prick and a half this piece of
poopy
i'm gonna wiggle out of here i'm gonna
wiggle waggle my way out of here
there we go hell yeah i'm
alive that [ __ ] stole my key
an entry to a small cellar maybe the
pantry really
wire wire i'm hurt i could use these
rags to craft some bandages and heal
myself
all right you got it bud bandages
and lock pick interesting
all right how about we well first let's
um
let's use the bandage oh
there we have it the controls are gonna
take some getting used to
unlocked shovel
it's heavy but it has good reach and
flashlight
all right so i gotta put those there
and there let's tear this a hole 10 new
a-holes
this barricaded too strong to dismantle
all right
how about i bash it womp
womp coming for you baby
it's no longer usable well that's a
problem because it seems like he might
still be
you know oh no i'll fight you dude
i'll fight you i'll fight you dude
i'll fight oh i'll fight you dude okay
i mean i just saw him so i probably
should push
go oh wrong
code who's there i don't know who is it
please let me out you know
maybe is he in the house
oh hey
[Music]
i don't like that i don't like none of
that
better not leave the house at night it's
safer here what do you mean it's safer
here
there's a maniac oh if i move this
yes yes yes
[Music]
hello ah this looks great
this all looks very good a metal table
with leather belts strapped onto it
right great search yeah turn my back
yeah it's fine
probably oh
okay wait i got a table leg all right
i'll use the table leg
okay let's refill it gluggity glug
tank is empty i don't know if i was
supposed to use all of it
okay generators on good man
good you know good
this is all kinds of good i feel very
good about this
maybe i could bash the thing out to get
the guy out of there
four eight nine two who said that
what
what four eight nine you know okay
four eight nine
two got it hey
hey hey who's here hey who's here come
on don't be shy
open up there we are help who
who's there i can't hear you come closer
i don't like it i don't trust it
i'm coming oh god ow
ow james i'm you hit like a truck
except you don't actually it's not that
much damage
yum okay good dead man i killed him a
small plastic chick
i hate it
and how do you want to get out now i
don't know
you think you can manage all by yourself
i don't know
hear it i don't know
hey
oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh my god
all right man hey good stuff hey
whoa that was radical
good for me for doing the
killing thing and escaping question mark
and
probably dying oh
i don't like your hand i i don't need it
great cool you know this is really
awesome
hell of a star i don't even know if the
prologue was that intense when i first
played it in 2014
who knows hey hey hey where am i
where am i what am i doing okay a
pleasant warmth is emanating from the
oven i can sense a strange yet familiar
sense
it's the smell of the protective
substance which gives me relatively
safety after dark the vapors rising from
the huge cauldron are distributed all
over the house via long pipes
as long as i remain inside my hideout i
have a chance of surviving the night
okay examine the oven when i arrived
here a couple days ago the oven was
basically prepared
i just needed a lighter to ensure my
safety at night this cottage must have
been one of our hideouts
the inhabitants of these woods don't
need to inhale this revolting gas
the label on the bottle says staying out
of the reach of the protective substance
after nightfall results in immediate
death in 99 out of a hundred cases
it is advised to evenly spread the gas
inside the sleeping area
and does it just last forever warning
even a properly prepared substance does
not guarantee
100 safety remain vigilant it is
recommended to stay in well-lit indoor
areas to in order to minimize
the risk look inside the pot a small
empty cast iron pot i haven't used it
yet
i haven't felt any hunger or thirst
since the accident a few days ago i
can't stop thinking about one thing
these mushrooms these red
mushrooms they look so tasty maybe this
pot will prove useful
after all ah i too have a craving hunger
for red pulsating mushrooms
don't we all oh my goodness
i don't want to know what that is
actually i definitely want to know what
that is that looks super sweet
okay so what the hell number one am i
doing what the hell
uh am i where the hell am i
those are two separate questions and why
the hell
did i have a key with the number 21
why i don't know not my department
photo of a road the road home
droga dodomi
sure yeah bam
yesterday i barricaded one of the
windows if i wanted to stay there for
some time
i should do the same with the other
windows all right oh
crafty crafts crafting bench okay i
don't have enough materials to be able
to do that
okay so that's the front door that's
delightful
punk okay bear trap under the windows
still open looks like this night was
exceptionally uneventful
is my bed really here why would my bed
be here why would i have my bed here
this doesn't make any sense this seems
like an unwise decision
so my out of breath noise when i'm
running because i run by default
apparently and i don't do cardio
all right cool i think that was part of
the remain vigilant thing that i
definitely
did well build i don't have a well
saw use converts wood logs into planks
good that's good to know oh there's a
container oh
is there a radio that can tell me what
the code is because that would be
awfully convenient
okay i guess i'm out on my own do i have
an axe or something that i can like you
know
cut logs is that my objective for now
do i have an objective besides just
maybe get out
hey look big pulsating red mushroom sure
would
be a shame okay uh the generator is half
empty it contains enough gasoline for
one more night i should find a full can
in the house above the underground
entrance
there was an underground entrance at my
house where the hell was there an
underground entrance what are you
talking about
turn on the generator before dark hiding
in the shadows won't do you any good
they're coming either way
all right cool man all right sweet also
there's
there's a hole in my house underground
oh
the carpet i see it
wardrobe sorry okay
mushroom book ah utzitek
ziggrazabal with gospadarsky
that's a tasty looking definitely not a
dick
that's definitely not a dick 100
not dick definitely not anyway i'm gonna
drag you around i was wrong
i've never been more wrong anyway i'm
gonna go
there's a full gas tank under the house
somewhere okay
log found log and stone and nail
gray at least i don't have to chop down
log
are these heavy probably not too heavy
i'm very strong shove them in my pockets
pockets full of logs ah look man i don't
know what is what in this game yet you
can't just do that to me
well you told me that there was gonna be
delicious red mushrooms oh underground
entrance i found it okay
cool you said that there was going to be
delicious red mushrooms and yet
every time i go near them apparently i
die
i'm like wicked tired
this is the house i'll find the entrance
to the underground here corpse
man should have used this bandage before
you had a chance
all right oh god that was very close
all right uh backpack okay that's good
but i'm i'm now officially out of stuff
medium caliber bullet what's gooping
what is gooping is there anything i can
craft uh
bandages with alcohol good for heavy
ones i guess yeah
sure okay wardrobe
oh there's that i i need that i'll just
stuff the logs in there for now because
i i don't have what i need i
definitely need the uh thingamabob can i
just
pull out wait can i pull out the bread
and eat that
so prep bread for eating engage eating
yum yum yum and i i need to use a
bandage anyway because i was grievously
wounded
two rags damn bam
hello hello
got it nailed it okay so there's some
kind of a secret entrance
right there this guy oh i gotta move the
bookshelf
perfect oh
why did that move like that do i want to
know
harvest ah i shouldn't touch him
that's for sure okay do i enter it
is this a good idea to see it feels like
a bad idea why would i want to go to an
underground entrance this feels very bad
very bad oh i hate it i have no weapon
why would i come here i have a gasoline
can i don't
oh oh no
hello i'll take these please thank you
motorcycle magazine from this year from
this year
you're telling me that this stuff hasn't
been going on for long enough that even
a year has passed
that's strange i really need like a
torch or something i have nothing
thick wood posts barely hold the soaked
ground in the tangled roots
the construction seems on the verge of
collapse you know what actually i'm
okay i'm gonna you know i don't even
think i could breathe i had a lung icon
and my cautious brain is telling me that
it was a bad idea to do any of that so
i'm gonna go back home because i
actually have
uh some stuff that is probably good
i've got like a oh whoops i lit a match
why did i light a match
stop lighting matches it is creepy
i gotta admit this is quite creepy
all right let me convert some of these
apparently it has fuel
all right that's cool that's pretty dope
all right i'm gonna move this up here
i'm gonna fill up my generator
and that way i'll be ahead one more
night right
mushies are these actually good to eat
or are you just
[ __ ] with me because i have a bad
idea i have a bad
idea feeling that it's just gonna be bad
i'll refill it okay tank empty i didn't
want to keep that
so i guess i'll go all right let me
barricade these
this seems like a good idea definitely
seems like a good idea
thong thunk alanka how many more
can i do i can do plenty
funka lunka clunka all right what do i
do about the big gaping hole in my house
can i build this well i have one i
thought i had more
so apparently i don't but or whatever i
can go get more
or actually no i need to put fuel in the
thing i need to make
how do i know what time it is is it
almost night it feels like it's getting
dark
is it getting dark
how do i know when it's dark it feels
like it's getting dark oh my god oh my
god
oh my god oh my god oh my god it feels
like it's getting dark
is it dark
[Music]
i got 10 essence
great oh it feels dark one eternity
later it's not dark i would know i would
know if it was dark
it's just that normally it's like dark
you know what i mean
i'm gonna put the logs in my log pile
it's not dark it just is always like
this yeah
totally definitely okay i'm gonna go
back down
into this cellar i'm gonna
also grab some things that i might have
forgotten okay
no i wanted the mushies there's
apparently a dose of something i'll get
it on the way out
if i have space okay cool great
let's go baby hey how you doing down
here
hey this looks great
oh no
[Music]
oh no
okay oh
corpsey warpsy i'm sure it'll stay dead
[Music]
okay i'll go back that way
oh no oh no
huh oh i won't be able to open it
without my key look at the handle
okay 21 21
the hatch handle is covered in a thick
layer of dust it hasn't been opened for
at least two weeks
you press your ear against the keyhole
all right i can hear a faint voice
through the howling wind
it sounds familiar it seems to be coming
through the keyhole someone is calling
me
hey unlock it from the other side look
through the keyhole
oh yeah i trust that dot dot
i see all right okay so
i guess i have to
oh no that's not good that's not good
this part of the password is blocked
player
i'm into harvest you i didn't see you
god ah
oh geez oh do i have a i have the
grievous bandage maybe i just need a
normal bandage
yaw cheese there's probably a quicker
way to do that
use them's perfect i feel so good
all right let's get going
oh my oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh odd meat okay
great yeah i just pulled some odd meat
out of the big
pulsating vagina in the ground is
good i feel good about that yeah i
wonder why that corpse was by it huh
weird winky dinks down to this
underground
come on oh no i'm out of breath please
don't be chasing me
please please don't it's chasing me
[Applause]
i didn't what don't back up into the
food man this is
unpleasant okay i gotta get my key
you know i'll get it eventually but some
weirdo took it from me unless that was
all in the future in which case it
didn't happen
silly stupid idiot all right
again i don't exactly know when daylight
is over
it's all pretty dark you know it's like
some kind of
dark wood barf
oh no please no poochie why why
poochie why why would you be mean like
that i'll give you a home
i'll give you a home poochie i'll give
you a nice home you'll love it there was
a crate back there that i wanted to
check but i couldn't check it because
poochie
is it a tractor all right i've only got
space for one more thing and then i
gotta head back
again don't know when the whole sun go
down
moose probably shouldn't mess with a
moose
oh oh whoa
this is just me or is the light getting
a little more orange
is that indicative of sunset
okay i think i gotta get back oh i
definitely gotta get back
oh i should have been back a while ago
oh god i need to get back oh no and i
left the generator on god i'm an idiot
oh no i'm so dumb i left the generator
on okay i've got extra uh gasoline
i just need to uh put it here and i'm
gonna
oh my god yes i'm aware i get it
it's almost nightfall i'm so incredibly
dumb
okay it didn't seem like it did that bad
i'm actually gonna save some
ow i'm gonna save some because i'm gonna
put some in the wood
chopper okay i'm gonna actually yoinkus
get filled baby okay and then
nope i know i have log and i
have log here
okay i'm gonna build this well whatever
it do
i built the well i'll drink from that oh
god close it close it close it close it
close it close it close it barricade it
yes good idea okay i feel safe
i feel very safe okay that is definitely
nightfall outside that's what nightfall
looks like it's definitely night
maybe it is i don't know i think i got
some meat ew
okay extract 12 essences extract yeah
great i don't have enough for a dose if
i wouldn't have just kept slamming my
dick into all the mushrooms around there
i might have been able to get a full
dose but i don't have that oh that's
night all right oh that's definitely
night
good night night go night night can i go
night night time every time i try to
look at the bed it doesn't want to give
me the option
maybe i gotta find my pillow before i
can go nighty night
oh no oh no
oh freak oh my freaking
freaka freak me
holy freaking freckle look
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
that's the most terrifying thing i've
ever experienced
that's horrible why did the door open
sure wish i could just take a nice nap
do you really just have to wait through
the night
horrible
i don't like where this music is going
hey i made it
oh what the hell happened to my oh it's
all
what what i don't know what all the
fibers is but what a beautiful morning
[Music]
hi even from afar i can smell your
putrid stench
be glad i don't have an appetite for
carcasses meat the figure hides its face
under the hood it smells of wet
soil and fur i know what you're after
i can help you proclaim what you've lost
if you help me attend to a certain
matter
what do you say comrade as he leans
towards me i can hear him giggling under
the hood
i knew you i would interest you before
we make a deal you need to prove that
you can do the job
i've no time for weaklings meat you
follow show me what you're made of
get through the silent forest you think
it's so easy
if i were you i would prepare myself
well before setting out
when you get there you'll find me in
this spot remember it
the wolf grabs my map and scribbles
something on it the likes of you
always crawl back to me
i'll show you like this beautiful item
perfect for a church fair
photo of a road what's that you got
there the wolf snatches the photograph
on my hand and studies it carefully
finally he snorts his thick yellow spit
landing on the photo
this road doesn't exist anymore
overgrown with trees like all the other
ones
the wolf throws the photo to the ground
better forget about
the road home meet around here all roads
lead to nowhere
alright gossip i wouldn't recommend
rendering these woods at night
it would mean certain death for you meat
better hiding that hide out of yours
before dark
and pray for the morning light gossip
i'd avoid getting into trouble if i were
you or at least until you get a decent
weapon
trade oh reputation
well well well that's some cool stuff
but i have nothing to trade with okay
goodbye if you wish to spend some more
quality time basking in the striking yet
natural beauty of my features before you
head off to the silent forest
you'll find me in my camp in the dry
meadow
thanks get out of my house get the hell
out of god get the hell out of here
all right anyway that's all the time i
got for this episode
but this is cool either they've polished
it up incredibly or i don't remember
just how scary it actually was
but there's a lot here so i might play
this again i was gonna just do a one-off
but it actually interests me i might do
this
again but thank you let me know what you
thought down in the comments below leave
a like if you enjoyed and subscribe and
ring the bell for more
cool videos coming your way and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye